lauren beauberg the congresswoman from
colorado she was having none of this uh
she got up on the floor of the house and
she's like okay so let me get this
straight paul gosar got censured not for
any of the anti-semitic hangings out or
any of his prior bizarre statements but
for an anime meme
and um should we sum up what some
members of this congress have done wrong
lauren bobert just bringing the hammer
good for her i mean honestly
since the speaker has designated the
floor to discuss members inappropriate
actions
shall we
the jihad squad member from minnesota
has paid her husband and not her brother
husband the other one over a million
dollars in campaign funds this member is
allowed on the foreign affairs committee
while praising terrorists
and then the cherry on top
my colleague and three-month
presidential candidate from california
who is on the intelligence committee
slept with fang fang a chinese spy let
me say that again a member of congress
who receives classifieds
sleeping with the enemy this is
unacceptable and this would never
generally has time to expire gentlemen
from florida
um
winner winner chicken dinner lauren
bobert uh points to lauren bobert right
there uh
yup
yup see here's the thing guys either no
one gets centered or everybody gets
injured that's the way that this has to
work
because here's the thing she's correct
congress is full of derelicts congress
is full of people who not only say
terrible things but do terrible things
it is rather incredible that eric
swallow retains his committee
assignments despite the fact that he was
screwing a chinese spy that is kind of
an amazing thing
meanwhile ilhan omar got very upset with
lauren bobert
for for mentioning not her brother
husband the other one
and she tweeted luckily my dad raised me
right otherwise i might have gone to the
floor to talk about this insurrectionist
who sleeps with a pervert i what i like
there is where she flatters herself that
her dad raised her right otherwise i
might have said this thing that i'm
saying right now in a tweet
i'm grateful i was raised to be a decent
human that is not
true and not a deprived person who
shamefully defecates and defiles the
house of representatives you can't
defecate the house of representatives
you can defecate on the house of
representatives
praise god
so
first of all uh the the thing that she's
referencing there sleeps with a pervert
is that her husband not
not beaubert did anything wrong her
husband was arrested for like uh an
indecent exposure a couple of years ago
but ilhan omar getting into family
issues is real awkward like real awkward
she's got a follow the house of usher
thing going on in her own family
and uh and not just that even if you put
aside the uh as lauren buber calls it
the alleged brother husband uh you will
have to recall that she also did in fact
pay a couple of million bucks to her
current husband's firm she was allegedly
having an affair with her current
husband while she was married with the
last husband she does have kids
she's a disaster of a human also she is
just a terrible jew-hating anti-semite
who has never been i mean they they
thought about censuring her they thought
about at least saying something in
congress about her and the democrats
like no we'll just pass a resolution
saying that all forms of hate are bad
by the way johanna omar still has no
answer to the charges of anti-semitism
she's asked by chris hayes about the
jewish community and she's like i'm just
not going to answer this
obviously a lot of jewish folks in your
district you have a lot of synagogues
you have it's a very vibrant jewish
world in the twin cities what those
relationships are like what those
conversations have been like because i
do know people that
have pretty progressive politics that i
do think
have been offended or have questioned uh
your your heart on these matters and i
know that's happened in your district
i'm curious what those conversations
have been like yeah i mean i i think
communities are not monolithic you know
there's different ideologies people have
there's different perspectives and
different places um where where people
come from and there are different
relationships people have with me that
sort of inform a positive reaction to
anything i say or a negative reaction to
anything that i say i'm just gonna
sidestep that get you hitting
anti-semitism right there by the way the
democratic party the democratic party
still has received talib as a member of
good standing there's a person who
hobnobs with pro-terror advocates openly
and joe biden was praising her yesterday
like not a year ago yesterday okay so
spare me the crocodile tears on the oh
my god paul gosar put out an anime meme
it's all just posturing it's uh you want
to know why people hate politics because
we all know that all these people are
full of absolutely extraordinarily toxic
levels of crap they're all septic at
this point
the battle for the culture is heating up
we here at the daily wear are making
some big moves so be sure to like
subscribe ring that bell because you're
not going to want to miss a single
moment